let's get some practice solving some
equations and we're going to set up some
equations that a little bit hairier than
normal they're going to have some
decimals and fractions in them so let's
say I had the equation 1.2 times C is
equal to 0.6 so what do I have to
multiply times 1.2 to get 0.6 and it
might not jump out immediately in your
brain
but lucky for us we can think about this
a little bit methodically so one thing I
like to do is say okay I already have to
see on the left hand side and I'm just
multiplying it by 1.2 it'd be great if
this just said see if this just said C
instead of one point two C so what could
I do there well I could just divide by
one point two but as we've seen multiple
times you can't just do that to the left
hand side that would change that would
you no longer could say that this is
equal to that if you only do if you only
operate on one side so you have to
divide by one point two on both sides so
on your left hand side one point to C
divided by one point two well that's
just going to be C you're going to be
left with C and you're going to have C
is equal to zero point six over one
point two now what is that equal to and
there's a bunch of ways you can approach
it the way I like to do it is well let's
just let's just get rid of the decimals
let's multiply the numerator and the
denominator by a large enough number so
that the decimals go away so what
happens if we multiply the numerator and
the denominator by let's see if we
multiply them by 10 you're going to have
a you're going to have six in the
numerator and a 12 in the number
actually let's do that so let's multiply
the numerator and the denominator by 10
so once again this is the same thing as
multiplying by 10 over 10 it's not
changing the value of the fraction so
0.6 times 10 is 6 and 1.2 times 10 is 12
is 12 so it's equal to 6 12 and if we
want we can write that in a little bit
of a simpler way we could rewrite that
as to divide the numerator and
denominator by 6 you get 1 over 2 so
this is equal to 1/2 and if you look
back at the original at the original
equation 1.2 times 1/2 well you could
view this is 12 10
twelve tenths times one half is going to
be equal to six tenths so we can feel
pretty good that C is equal to one half
let's do another one let's say that we
have one say we have 1 over 4 is equal
to Y over 12 so how do we solve for y
here so we have a y on the right hand
side and it's being divided by 12 well
the best way I could think of of getting
rid of this 12 and just having Y on the
right hand side is by multiplying both
sides by 12 let me do that in yellow so
if I multiply the right-hand side by 12
I have to multiply the left-hand side by
12 and once again why did I pick 12 well
I wanted to multiply by some number that
when I multiply it by Y over 12 I'm just
left with Y and so Y times 12 divided by
12 well that's just going to be 1 and
then 12 and then you're on the left hand
side you can have 12 times 1/4 which is
12 fourths so you get 12 over 4 12 over
4 is equal to Y or you could say Y is
equal to 12 over 4 Y is equal to let me
do that in that just so you see what I'm
doing I'm just swapping the sides
doesn't change what's being said Y is
equal to 12 over 4 now what is 12
fourths well you can view this as 12
divided by 4 which is 3 or you could
view this as 12 fourths which would be
literally three wholes
so you could say this would be equal to
3y is equal to 3 and you could check
that 1/4 is equal to 3 over 12 so it all
works out that's the neat thing about
equations you can always check to see if
you got the right answer
let's do another one can't stop four
point five is equal to zero point five
and so like always I have my n already
on the right-hand side so but but it's
been multiplied by 0.5 would be great if
it was just an N so what can I do well I
can divide both sides I can divide both
sides by 0.5 once again if I do to the
right-hand side I have to do to the
left-hand side and why am i dividing by
0.5 so I'm just
with an N on the right-hand side so this
is going to be so on the left-hand side
I have four point five over 0.5 now let
me just don't wanna skip too many steps
four point five over zero point five
over zero point five is equal to n
because you have zero point 5 divided by
zero point five you're just left with an
N over here so what is that equal to
well four point five divided by 0.5
there's a couple of ways to view that
you could view this as 45 tenths divided
by five tenths which would tell you okay
so that's just going to be nine or if
that seems a little bit confusing or a
little bit daunting you can do what we
did over here we could multiply the
numerator the denominator by the same
number so we get rid of the decimals and
in this case you multiply by ten you can
move the decimal one to the right so
once again it has to be multiplying the
numerator denominator by the same thing
we're multiplying by ten over ten which
is equivalent to one which tells us that
we're not changing the value of this
fraction so let's see this is going to
be 45 45 over 5 over 5 is equal to N and
some of you might say wait wait wait
wait hold on a second Sal you just told
us that whatever we do to one side of an
equation we have to do to the other side
of the equation and here you are you're
just multiplying the left-hand side of
this equation by 10 over 10 now remember
what is 10 over 10 10 over 10 is just 1
yes if I wanted to I could multiply the
left-hand side by 10 over 10 and I could
multiply the right-hand side by 10 over
10 but that's not going to change the
value of the right-hand side I'm not
actually changing the values of the two
sides I'm just trying to rewrite the
left-hand side by multiplying it by 1 in
kind of a creative way but notice n
times 10 over 10 well that's still going
to just be n so I'm not violating this
principle of whatever I do to the
left-hand side and do the right-hand
side you can always multiply one side by
one and you can do that as many times as
you want like the same way you could add
zero or subtract zero from one side
without necessarily having to show
you're doing it to the other side
because it doesn't change the value but
anyway you have n is equal to 45 over 5
well what's 45 over 5 well that's going
to be 9 so we have 9 is equal to why did
I switch to green
we have we have nine is equal to n or we
could say n is equal to nine and you
could check that four point five is
equal to zero point five times nine yep
half of 9 is four point five
let's do one more because once again I
can't stop alright now let me let me get
some space here so we can keep keep the
different problems apart that we had so
let's do let's do let's change let's
have a different variable now let's say
we have G over four is equal to three
point two well I want to get rid of this
dividing by four so the easiest way I
can think of doing that is multiplying
both sides by four so I'm multiplying
both sides by four and the whole reason
is so because I have four divided by
four gives me one so I'm going to have G
is equal to what's three what's three
point two times four let's see three
times four is twelve and two tenths
times four is is eight tenths so it's
going to be twelve and eight tenths it's
go G is going to be twelve point eight
and you can verify this is right twelve
point eight divided by four is three
point two